a few years ago I was in Hong Kong I was
doing a story for Vox and I went to this
giant bridge and I flew my drone over it
it was this big story and a while back I
was like does the United States have any
big super cool bridges that do all this
cool stuff like in the ocean turns out
we do it's not nearly as big but we have
this bridge the Chesapeake Bridge which
is four and a half miles long and
apparently it's the scariest bridge in
America I've driven over this bridge a
bunch because it's like 20 miles from my
house and I never thought it was that
scary but apparently a lot of people
think it's really scary so much so that
there's an entire service where you
could go show up with your car and there
will be someone waiting for you and they
will get in your car and they will drive
you across the bridge if you're afraid
so we have ourselves a nice big bridge
that's apparently super scary because
there's nowhere to pull off on and if
you need to go across it there is
someone there that will do it for you
and they've got a great infomercial in
case you need to be convinced